do you like that what am i eating again
I forgot I'm here to eat some sort of
international food snack I figured that
was the case you're gonna ask me to do
some weird
I don't need an insect I hope it's
someone that's not gonna try to harm me
violently I don't think we're allowed to
eat poop on camera right that's exactly
what I already wanted to do this is
gonna completely ruin this for the rest
of my life this is so mean this is maybe
the most exciting day of my life
double quarter-pounder with cheese which
is what I was gonna get your lunch in
the pic 15 minutes and a Crunchwrap
supreme alright this is a breakfast
burrito from the jack-in-the-box and
it's a two-piece from Popeye this is a
maxi melts sausage McMuffin with egg
talk about classic taco in and out
cheeseburger animal style protein style
you just want me to do it on this table
it's gonna be so gross
she's just wonderful how do you want to
fit together friends feel like what I
need to do is empty it out into the
sandwich do you think it's gonna be good
yeah I feel like we can just put this
crunch rep in the middle of this
cheeseburger I could just put the taco
in the burger
and then do a little wrap around this is
actually kind of beautiful I basically
put a two piece in biscuit into an
already breakfast burrito in an out
burger garden style with a taco right in
the middle oh my god there's like
Christmas I'll take my lactaid pills
first so I don't die Oh looks gross this
may be the most delicious thing I've
ever eaten in my entire life man I don't
think there's a more distinct taste than
that ground beef from Taco Bell holy
this sausage is like overpowers a lot of
things it doesn't even taste like talked
about or McDonald's anymore it's like
another thing they're way better
separated they complement each other
really well I'm just soulful klimt at
how excited I am about this I'm gonna
cry this is really good the sensory
overload would be the perfect way to
explain this burrito it's a little bit
too many meats and you can always use
the tortilla as a napkin it's right now
one of my favorite things can ruin my
other favorite thing this is definitely
like been enjoying it in the privacy of
your own home food I don't deserve this
sandwich maybe that was really drunk
this is all I can have now I can't go to
one of these restaurants anymore I'm
just so thankful that I got to
experience that it's something I always
wanted to do but I never really knew
that like it was a possibility I would
probably never do it again
you learned something new every day and
what I've learned is that if you mix
Taco Bell in in and out it's pretty good
the meat sweats oh they're happening
already